right deshawn watson now facing 19
lawsuits and one of the three lawsuits
filed today
alleges that he deleted instagram
messages and
also has contacted some of the massage
therapists
directly in an effort to settle
the cases now it's unclear whether the
allegation is that he has
contacted massage therapists who sued
or whether other ones who have yet sued
there's a subtle and it's a little too
inside baseball from the legal
profession standpoint
reason as to why it's worse and it's
more delicate to contact people who've
already sued you because they're
represented by council
either way it's been denied by rusty
hardin deshaun watson's lawyer the
bottom line is miles
this thing is showing no indication
no sign no evidence that it's going to
go away
quickly and cleanly i've been advocating
for days now that desean watson needs to
have a mediation with all of these
individuals in a room with a retired
judge
or an experienced lawyer who can give
everyone something that feels like their
day in court
everyone can come out of this with some
sort of satisfaction and desean watson
can put
this behind him and again when i say
that i'm not saying make it go away
i'm saying deal with it resolve it
in a mature responsible fashion
instead of having it hang over your life
and your career
for the next two years or longer well
right i think
you're saying that he should use the
processes that
are available to him in order to take
some sort of accountability
which i think is different than saying
make it go away i
think that there is a large difference
between those two different things and
i think you're right mike because the
more this continues
uh the more allegations that continue to
come out against him
the more that this is going to just
continue
to be a cloud that hangs over his head
and not just his career but also in his
life
so at a certain point i think you're
right he just
has to be able to get this into some
sort of mediation and some sort of
process
for tim to take accountability and then
for this
to be able to uh be so that he can be
able to put this
in its proper place in his life and then
take accountability for
what apparently are allegedly are his
actions
and here's the problem with that because
even though tony busby who represents
these 19
plaintiffs says it's not about money i
mean it is about money
he's being disingenuous when he claims
it isn't he's just trying to score
points in the court of public opinion
however if there's urgency
from watson to settle the case
that's a factor in determining what is
a fair outcome see this is part of the
problem
of from watson's perspective being
painted into a corner
by tony busby because if you want to
resolve this quickly
it's going to cost you it's going to
cost more
to resolve it now because it's in your
interests
to resolve it now so you can remove this
cloud
from your career so you can remove this
distraction
from your life you want it to go away
that's part of what you're paying for
that's part of the business transaction
and i know it seems crass
to have it all boiled down to dollars
and cents but that's how
the civil justice system works that's
why it offends me for busby to try to
tell us it's not about money
it's inherently about money that's the
commodity that you use to resolve either
through settlement or a
judgment a claim of this nature that's
it
that's the only way to resolve it and
the question becomes what's the fair
amount now
for these 19 cases to ultimately be
resolved so deshaun watson can get on
with his life by the way
we wrote something earlier today based
on a houston chronicle item
suggesting that or reporting that desean
watson's sponsors have yet to abandon
him
including nike beats by dre and rolex
i wouldn't be so sure about nike uh
there's reason to think that nike may be
thinking about ending its relationship
with the sean watson
i'm told well if they are then
again there's certainly good reason for
it based on what is out there not just
from these
19 lawsuits but then also as you
mentioned uh before we went to break the
the sports illustrated article or
essay.com article that came out today i
mean there's
certainly some stuff in there that i
would not be surprised
uh if it made nike feel some sort of
trepidation about working with him in
the future
yeah i mean look it's all pr and this
court has been tried extensively or this
case rather and these cases have been
tried extensively in the court of public
opinion
as to the allegation miles that desean
watson has been deleting instagram
messages
and contacting massage therapists
directly rusty harden his attorney
issued a statement shortly after
reporters began to focus on those
allegations in one of the three new
lawsuits here's what
hardin's statement had to say uh and of
course my eyes are going to be
hard-pressed to read this
um and i can see it now like i'm like
i'm like
at the at the doctor doing the eye test
like a lot of people desean regularly
deletes past instagram messages that
said he has not deleted any messages
since march 15 the day before the first
lawsuit was filed
we categorically deny that he has
reached out directly to his accusers in
an attempt to settle these cases
the thing about deleting the instagram
messages
as of march 15 the day before the first
case was filed he supposedly knew for a
while that something was coming
so that invites speculation as to
whether or not he may have deleted
something relevant to any of these cases
before the first one was filed at a time
when he
knew that something was happening i'm
more comfortable
with the statement if this had been the
true statement that he hasn't deleted
anything since the day before he first
became aware
that anyone was claiming that he engaged
in wrongdoing
because that's the point where i think
everything needs to freeze
and if anything is deleted you gotta
wonder number one what was deleted
and of course it can always be
reconstructed and number two
why did you delete it absolutely and i
believe the thing about instagram
messages if even if he were to delete
one of them and i could be totally wrong
and i probably shouldn't be since i'm a
millennial but
the other person might still have access
to that message so they can certainly be
reconstructed as you were just saying
anyway so i think when it is of that
nature and you say
you know before the day before these
things were first filed and they first
came out publicly
then yes that does raise a couple of
eyebrows and it should because
that it goes to whether or not
you know he was trying to cover
something up before
this became public knowledge another
thing that
that nags a lot of people and gnaws at a
lot of people and bothers a lot of
people including rusty harden
the reality that they still don't know
who any of these people are
they're all proceeding under the
pseudonym jane doe and the report today
from jennyvarentisofsi.com has
another unnamed massage therapist who
was granted anonymity now s.i
clearly vetting the person appropriately
coming to the conclusion that
her allegations are or at least based on
what she believes not
something that are being fabricated and
they can trust her but
with 20 people and not a single one of
them attaching a name to it
that at a certain point provides
ammunition for people who just say
something's not right here because when
antonio brown was sued for sexual
assault and rape
the name of the plaintiff brittany
taylor attached
to the lawsuit when ben rothersburg was
sued for rape in 2009
in nevada the name of the plaintiff
attached
to the lawsuit and i'm now at the point
miles and i really don't want to do this
i'm like
pacino and godfather three every time
i'm out they pull me back in
i'm gonna have to research texas law and
see exactly what
the procedural rules and requirements
and standards are
for filing suit under a john or jane doe
pseudonym because there has to be at
some point there has to be
a standard there had anybody because
anybody could do it whenever they wanted
to
if that was the case you could keep all
your business private and sue
for anything under a john doe or jane
doe pseudonym and i'm not suggesting
anyone's done anything wrong
with 20 people not attaching a name to
this
at a certain point especially with
desean watson's lawyer complaining about
it it does invite curiosity
as to whether or not there's any
argument that rusty harden may make
that these lawsuits aren't aren't
sufficient because the name hasn't been
supplied
well if you don't and if you don't have
a name supplied then it also makes it
more difficult to then investigate it
from
deshaun watson's perspective which i
believe is the point that rusty harden
has been making so
from that perspective it's okay
how can we then say if you're rusty hard
and you're sean watson's lawyer it's how
can we properly
investigate what this is and prove that
there was no wrongdoing
if we don't have all the facts because
they have not been properly presented to
us because
all of these things are being uh
presented under the name of jane doe so
from that standpoint you can sort of see
where they're coming from
however that doesn't mean that there was
no wrongdoing in the first place
correct correct and and look the rules
permitted
i'm just curious now with with 19
lawsuits and another individual
not attaching a name to it i'm becoming
curious as to what the standard is
because there's a chance
that maybe some of these individuals
meet it some don't maybe they all meet
it maybe none of them do
that just feels like one of the angles
that will be pushed on behalf of deshaun
watson so i want to try to get ahead of
it and figure out exactly what it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports